the holidays on Thanksgiving Americans
gather to break bread and share what
they're grateful for well what should
you do if you don't feel thankful maybe
your boss is a jerk maybe money's tight
maybe you're dreading awkward political
arguments with your relatives
whatever the reason you're not feeling
the holiday spirit so what are you
supposed to do three words act grateful
anyway
social science shows that choosing to
practice gratitude no matter how you
feel can itself make you more grateful
and happier too one 2003 study found
that people who kept a list of things
they were grateful for were
significantly more satisfied with their
lives than subjects who dwell on
negative or even neutral events instead
and thankfulness is contagious a 2011
study found that responding to an angry
person with warmth and gratitude disarms
their aggression and leads to better
behavior so here's the prescription for
the holiday blues forget about your
feelings and decide to count your
blessings it'll make you a happier
person and it'll probably make your
dinner companions happier too what do
you think about the research on
gratitude let us know in the comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI